[Musica]
[Applauso]
non ho bevuto sono le musichette che mi
fanno questo effetto
ok quella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vigenti e non
ci siamo su di unfair platform è un
videogame ragazzi tipo che marcia per
niente è un range game che aspetta che
mi piacciono da morire e siccome lo
chiedeva che tipo da un anno di giocarlo
ho cercato di evitare di farlo però non
avete continuato quindi non c'è verso
una maglia dei baristi giochi che ti
insegnano come muoverti come se fossi un
cerebroleso però poi non riesce a fare
un passo perché ci sono trappole quindi
che cazzo ti spieghi questi messaggi
diranno sempre la verità sicuramente
guardava conosco talmente bene i reds
che vede dopo un paio di volte e chiaro
che non ci casco più
ok perfetto non volevo fare questo ma va
bene così questa è una trappola giocato
talmente tanto ai regi game che so di
per certo che con la una puttanata
quindi badin quella dopo mi sta
prendendo per il culo ragazzi siccome
rete per tovaglia di prenderci per il
culo io ho scelto direttamente avanti
quindi se ma ecco perfetto le bandiere
blu sono check point per fallo a questo
sì ok ragazzi ci siamo almeno almeno
checkpoint l'ho preso almeno questo
porca la vediamo di andare avanti
ok ok sto saltando a caso
sappi che avevo fatto tutto non è
possibile avevo saltato tutti gli
ostacoli posti è lo sapevo che era una
trappola che non ha idea di come abbia
fatto però sono morto ok
sì ma vaffan rega non mi piace allora è
perché solo da me l'avete consigliata
nei nei nei mesi cioè non è che me ne
una roba dell'ultimo momento quindi non
ho capito bene a puntare mi son
dimenticato caminati che non devo
parlando stare zitto perché se lo faccio
il deficiente minchia vediamo di capirci
mezzo secondo prima di lanciare tutto ok
e massei lurida ragazzi non è nono sì sì
ok mi sono salvato di brutto non so
neanche come sono morto traiano ci posso
riuscire di nuovo forse sì si no 5
fottuti minuti di gioco 27 morti 28
posso incazzarmi sempre di più allora sì
sì no no
ok è di tutti è che sforzo sovraumano
allora no non cambierò ok non è una
trappola
non è una trappola perfetto madornali
schiaffi in faccia o tecnica no che
madonna mi sto sabato per culo ok
perfetto allora bene il look like it's
the end of di level perfetto ragazzi già
questo fa ho saltato di sicuro una
trappola o presa da presa senza lo
scalino lo so lo so che era una non
c'erano trappole da qualche parte non so
dove ma c'erano il portando ragazzi che
ce l'abbia fatta perché non è possibile
next level sono già morto
perché chi adesso mi fate parti niente
sono mario non ce la facciamo anche a
partire
ok perfetto allora è una ascensore che
figo
questo no bene che cazzo stoffa ecco lo
sapeva sentite o niente che non ce la
faccio io non impossibile
ok ok regalo ce l'ho fatta non so chi è
sono quasi però sono qua dai ci possiamo
lavorare mi sono stando tutto il livello
praticamente solo che ok ok no non si
prega perfetto
non ci credo sì grandezze materia tanto
muoio di sicuro perché non tanto lo
sapeva no no di andrea delfino salto di
brutto ok no niente madre deve morire in
tutti i modi possibili
ok
[Musica]
niente giacché essa alto della madonna
salto decente ma che botta di culo a
segno questo momento me lo ricordo per
tutta la vita non ci posso credere
ok queste cose sfere del drago
no no che trovero quasi mia in treno in
testa alle cose
ok non ci sono tre non è possibile come
fanno a non esserci trappole
spiegatemelo ragazzi alla fine la fine
si l'ho finito ma veramente non mi stai
prendendo per il culo non è possibile
ho vinto non ci posso credere a posso
saltare sulla testa rene miccoli nemici
a ok
che bello che si però sono tutti stronzi
anche questi prof horse e se se perfetto
bene così raga benissimo le sfere del
drago le metto tutte nel culo perché
sono molto amico non mi ricordo dove
sono morto e che potrebbe essere un
problema questo salta devo andare ok qua
sopra quello che cazzo vado scusate se
tutte uguali come faccio a sapere quello
che mi tengono ok o capire ogni 2 lega
ma non è possibile stavolta no stavolta
mi fotte di brutto vado avanti non mi
sono fatto forte le manca mori e faith
walk cammino della fede
vuol dire che se vado avanti non che
hanno un casco figo ad evitare i fulmini
però bellissimo
no ragazzi la mia coordinazione è la
stessa di un pratico commento che tra
poco la fine cerci con trappole sicure
lo sapevo tanto vinto
che cazzo voluto provare a tornare
indietro lo so solo io non sono un
demente come pochi perfetto ok nuovo il
mio culo di qua che non arriva a mia
madre dimmi che devo spegnere perché ok
perfetto perché a caminate la madonna
cosa sto schifo
vabbè vabbè ci mettiamo anche tipo un
lady gaga spara conchiglie da qualche
parte non già che ci siamo cosa può fare
qua che bordello oggi io sfiga che parto
nel momento sbagliato oppure non c'è ok
donna ma donna prega finché avrò no no
no no no deve morire il cugino questo
caso ho fatto prima non ne pronuncia
farò mai più
invece sì invece si no cambi lega calmi
perfetto perfetto su sì sì sì sì sì
furono niente domande non ne voglio
sapere cioè che sto schifo devo andare
avanti prima che miraggio se va beh
certo voglia di prepara anche un caffè
nel frattempo non lo so sì sì sì sì no
no ma minchia perché mario è certo se
magari mi avvicino la sedia che sto
giocando dal tibet applausi perché non è
possibile cioè non con tutto rispetto
per chi ha creato sto gioco
vado vado direttamente sul
sulla fine quando sulla fine si si si si
non muoverti mica tanti di quegli
schiaffi che giuro che lo rimpiange rai
per tutta la vita perfetto il next level
ce ne sono di livello giusto per sapere
di che morte morire probabilmente questa
è una roba troppo strano o che luca luca
da madonna cos'è sta roba
l'ho preso l'ho preso l'ho preso l'ho
preso non mi fanno incazzare brava forza
sì sì sì sì no no no no non ho mica mi
stava portando non so dove potevo
incazzarmi alla felicità tutta destra
perfetto nell eterna felicità ragazzi
perché è proprio questa credo
sicurissimo che sia questa lo prendo non
lo prendo perché tanto so che mi fotte
perfetto io sto saltando cose
se sì cosa ho saltato delle trappole non
so dove grazie grazie mille sono gli dei
dell'olimpo che mi buttano sulla testa
tonnellate di sterco di capra che
perfetta minchiate schivata ok madonna
madonna no no come se un caduto e sto
facendo un miracolo ci ho messo 40
minuti per fare quello che ho appena
fatto e non ce la farò mai più
sì sì ok perfetto come quel c'è
poi tradizione allora devo trovare si no
se si definisce dove finisca e finisca e
finisca
c'è chi and the wall plaining però che
tu non sia diventato troppo pazzo giuro
che ti prendo a calci da caldo ragazzi è
stato veramente bello distruttivo
soprattutto e rilassante elemento
ragazzi vi ringrazio di cuore per amico
sia giusto gioco e tutti gli altri
bellissimi giochi che mi consigliate
sempre voglio abbracciare però velo
adesso perché devo andarmi a sfogare
contro il muro attestate quindi la
prossima volta
i ragazzi servito vi è piaciuto come sia
stato un momento mi piace anche la fase
di facebook e come non è dotata la
descrizione accese l'avresti d'ischia
principi diano prossimo vita è colpa del
gioco belle ragazze